what's the theory behind starting a
session of C Rises second have big cats
of course how could I forget I would say
there's two different types of training
sessions so it's like a training session
where you're like going in there to die
and remove your own soul and look at it
like deep into its own eyes and then put
it back into yourself and then there's
training sessions where it's like more
social training session I'm trying to
make puffy a thing big back puff stop
trying to make puff happen how much do
you value the skin on the back of your
thumb arguably the highest skin really
think about ah lots of people in America
are circumcised don't they I forget yeah
I'm be the only person in this building
with a forkin that's crazy probably
we'll cut that one from the re just like
he
got see what it did there Alex do train
his chest because he says his chest
doesn't need to grow anymore some of us
don't have that problem might have been
nice we have done some chest yeah I'm
all puffed up oh my legs are all puffed
right now dude I'm getting puffy my arms
are puffed I'm like 3/4 puffed not full
puffed puffy will never be a thing
Puffy's going to be huge it makes me
uncomfortable every time that I hear you
say it stay puffy